Es wird ein irres
wissenschaftliches ereignis bald schon werden wir das erste abbild eines schwarzen loches zu sehen bekommt bisher war dies nicht möglich zu viele schwierigkeiten
Gibt es ein echtes bild zu machen aber
Forschungsteams haben das größte radioteleskop der welt zusammen gebaut und im april dieses
Foto gemacht doch erst jetzt kann es berechnet werden und da laufen die
großrechner auf hochtouren auf whatsapp haben viele nach dem stand der dinge gefragt hier ist der bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Der wahnsinn so ein schwarzes loch und eigentlich nichts besonderes
es scheint unglaubliche mengen davon zu geben was auch nicht verwundert denn eine
grundlegende eigenschaft eines schwarzen loches hat quasi jeder gegenstand sogar ein atom den schwarz schild radios
1916 kam der deutsche astronom carl schwarz schild auf die idee das ist bei jeder masse einen kugelförmigen
horizont geben müsse bei dem die
Gravitation so groß ist dass nichts mehr aus dieser kugel entweichen kann bei allem was wir sehen können ist dieser radius, so klein dass die
Außengrenze dieses radius der ereignishorizont so klein ist dass
Ich eben die materie außerhalb dieses horizonts befindet und damit sichtbar ist bei der sonne beträgt dieser schwarz schild radius
Beispielsweise drei kilometer sie hat eine masse von zwei quint millionen kilogramm da ist er
Genauso groß würde also die masse der sonne auf eine größe unter diesem radius
Zusammenstürzen dann würde ein mini schwarzes loch entstehen das geht aber nicht da ihr eigengewicht nicht groß
Genug ist um die kräfte die gegen die gravitation wirken zu überwinden war sternen die aber deutlich schwerer als die sonne sind
Passiert das wenn am ende die fusion zum erliegen kommt und sie als supernova explodieren und dann mehr als die dreifache
Sonnenmasse übrig bleibt dann ist deren gewicht so stark dass sie zu einem schwarzen loch
zusammenstürzen man kann sich das so vorstellen dass die gravitation
So stark ist dass auf unserer erde zum beispiel übertragen berge in sich
Zusammenstürzen wir selber wir menschen in die erde gezogen werden und es immer und immer dichter wird und dadurch die kräfte noch stärker
Werden weil sich die masse auf eine noch kleinere kugel verdichtet und am schluss forschungsteams weltweit vermuten einen
unendlich kleinen punkt
Im zentrum eines schwarzen loches aber letztendlich wissen wir es nicht bisher
Konnten wir schwarze löcher nur messen um sie herum kreis die materie und wird heißt bevor sie in das schwarze loch stürzt diese
Heiße strahlung können wir messen und so wissen wir wo schwarze löcher sind und das absolut irre ist wahrscheinlich gibt es auch
Im zentrum von galaxien und wahrscheinlich sogar in allen galaxien so ein schwarzes loch nur ist es
Die sich absolut gigantisch und enthält die masse von millionen sonnen oder milliarden ein super
massereiches schwarzes loch, im zentrum unserer milchstraße da haben wir ein solches schwarzes loch gefunden
Um das zentrum unserer milchstraße rasen nämlich sterne mit einem affenzahn
Der schnellste stern mit einem tempo von 18 millionen kilometern pro stunde alle 15 jahre hat er die runde
um
sagittarius a
Stern gemacht so wurde das schwarze loch in der mitte unserer galaxie nämlich benannt was diesen daten wissen wir übrigens
Also, aus der entfernung und der geschwindigkeit ziemlich. Genau wie groß das schwarze loch ist vier
millionen sonnenmassen hat es und einen schwarz schild radius von
12 millionen kilometern wir hier in unserem sonnensystem haben übrigens einen sicheren abstand von
26.000 nicht jahren zum zentrum da sind wir einigermaßen
sicher also das ist wirklich extrem bei den fährt aber ein foto von diesem schwarzen loch
Das können wir wegen dieser große entfernung einfach nicht machen es hat die größe eines tennisballs auf dem mond
Im vergleich und nicht nur das es so klein ist es ist auch so viel
Im weg dass es einfach nicht sichtbar ist da sind nebel aus gas und aus staub die einfach die sicht verwehren was
Also tun eigentlich ist es einfach aber dann auch wieder kompliziert
elektromagnetische wellen mit langen wellenlängen durchdringen diese nebel aber
Und jetzt kommt der haken die sind so langweilig dass ein bild davon nur sehr unscharf werden würde aber die forschungsteams
Waren erfinderisch was wäre wenn wir zu einem ein ganz viele radioteleskop zusammenschalten
Würden und was wäre wenn wir sie einige tage auf das schwarze loch richten
Ersteres würde das bild deutlich schärfer machen und durch die dauer der messung also diese
Mehreren tage würden wir viel mehr daten bekommen gesagt getan. Im april machte das event horizon
teleskop diese spektakuläre aufnahme zahlreicher
radioteleskope rund um die erde wurden zusammen geschaltet und richteten sich
Zeitlich zehn tage lang auf sagt carius a stern aus und jetzt soll schon bald das bild
Vorliegen es wird der hammer zumindest dass wir es sehen denn aufgrund der erdrotation der langen aufnahme wird es wahrscheinlich
sowie eine langzeitbelichtung mit entsprechenden schmieren und so weiter ja wie vielleicht dieses bild aussehen vielleicht können nur
Wissenschaftlerinnen etwas damit anfangen vielleicht wird es aber auch
Spektakulär die letzten daten zur berechnung sind aus der antarktis vom dortigen südpol teleskop am 13 dezember
2017 zum
High stake observatorien rechenzentrum in den usa ausgeflogen worden und werden jetzt berechnet
mitbeteiligt eine berechnung ist das rechenzentrum, am max planck institut für radioastronomie
In bonn es wird sehr sehr spannend was wir sehen werden in diesem
Gebiet ist die raumzeit nämlich unglaublich gegründet kann könnte also sehr seltsam aussehen aber und das ist unglaublich spannend
Wir werden hinter das schwarze loch sehen können denn es ist eine
gravitationslinse und wird uns unsere galaxie
Also die teile unserer galaxie hinter ihm zeigen wahnsinn ich bin
wahnsinnig gespannt meine frage an euch soll ich dann einen live stream zum thema machen also wie letztlich zum
Start der falcon heavy schreibt es unten in den kommentaren
wenn ihr
diesen live streamen nicht verpassen wollt und meine anderen videos
zu allen anderen themen dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video eben vorab
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
andere vorschläge machen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier drauf kriegen und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Mysteriöses schwarzes loch wirft theorie über schwarze löcher, um sehr sehr spannend ansonsten bis dann
bleibt da